[Music]
on this monday night
tracking the chain of covid 19
infections
canada's contact tracing app gets ready
for download
after alberta's app fell flat they have
to get it right
the tough task of finding out where
you've been and who you've been around
as police bust another overcrowded
weekend bash
the prime minister on the hot seat
justin trudeau prepares to testify this
week on the wii
charity controversy games turfed
the major league season is barely out of
the dugout and already
on deck to strike out plus jaw-dropping
fine the close encounter one family
calls
a dream come true
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
jeff semple good evening and thanks for
joining us
in places where covet 19 is making a
comeback canadian health officials blame
the bar scene and house parties where
crowds cram
indoors drinking alcohol and ignoring
physical distancing
which is why a weekend bash in brampton
west of toronto
is sparking a national outcry police say
they broke up a house party with about
200 guests
organizers allegedly tried to hide the
gathering by setting up barriers and
hiring private security to park cars
nearby
you got a bunch of yahoos again that the
number one hold the party
and then the whole bunch of 200 yahoo
show up to hold the put like guys
what like man come on like what don't
you get
like it's ridiculous absolutely
ridiculous
now the man who allegedly threw that
party told global news that he only
invited a couple dozen people but that
more showed up after guests posted about
the event online
he's now been fined 880 dollars and is
also facing
bylaw charges with a maximum penalty of
a hundred thousand dollars
and in alberta public health officials
are sounding the alarm after a major
spike in cases
304 more people have now tested positive
since friday
and eight more have died as we see in
the case numbers
the curve is no longer flat in alberta
we all need to assess our own lives for
where we were at risk of spreading or
contracting the virus
and case numbers are also rising fast in
saskatchewan
31 more people tested positive 22 of
whom are from hutterite communities
saskatchewan's premier says that in the
coming days public health officials will
visit every hutterite community in the
province
to offer testing and ensure that public
health orders are being followed
and key to getting those community
outbreaks under control
is contact tracing and soon there could
be an app for that
after weeks of delays canada is now
testing a new national smartphone app
to help with contact tracing heather
urix west looks at whether the
technology
deserves a download in a crowd of
strangers a single case of covid19 can
spread like
wildfire and the chains of infection can
be
difficult to trace if a contact tracer
calls you
on the phone and says you got a positive
test who are you near i don't know who i
was next to on the ttc i don't know
i don't know who i was at if i was at a
boy and restaurant this scenario is
exactly what has been facing contact
tracers in recent weeks
outbreaks at bars restaurants parties
and gyms have led to a surge
in infections but where a person's
memory fails
technology could help that's the premise
behind
contact tracing apps the way it works is
your phone
emits a signal over bluetooth and it's
kind of like a secret
key canada is now beta testing an app
based on technology developed by google
and apple
it can run in the background of
smartphone devices without draining the
battery
a key reason why alberta's app launched
earlier this year
appears to be falling short the app
tracks who you come into contact with
not where you've been i'm excited about
the potential of the notification app
i think it we should be really clear
that it's not uh not not about
contact tracing exactly but rather
notifying
people who have the app downloaded on
their phone if they've been
in close contact with someone who
eventually becomes diagnosed with covet
19.
the launch of this app has been delayed
in canada but experts say
that's not necessarily a bad thing the
one sure way of making not people use it
is if there's bugs or it's not user
friendly so i think it's really
important that they take their time to
get it right at the very beginning
success depends on widespread adoption
an oxford study found that 60 percent of
people need to use the apps or
they don't work but that concentration
doesn't necessarily have to be
population-wide if you have um
60 adoption but it's 100
among the young population
and the young adults who go out and
about
are the ones that sort of interact with
each other then
that may be beneficial
it's why with a growing number of young
people heading out to socialize
now might just be the best time for
canada's app to launch
heather urex west global news calgary
and infection rates are also climbing
around the world according to the world
health organization the number of cases
worldwide has roughly
doubled in just the last six weeks the
united states brazil and india have
topped the world's caseloads
but numbers are also rising in places
that had previously appeared to have the
virus under control
such as australia japan and spain
and since the start of the pandemic more
than 16 million cases have been reported
to the who
and more than 640 thousand people have
died
crystal gomansing has more on the global
picture including the man
known as asia's sickest patient
he is rail thin struggles to breathe
and walk back in march while working in
vietnam as a pilot
stephen cameron was diagnosed with
covid19
when i was under for 10 weeks in life
support
it's no laughing matter it's a very
serious thing and i think
people can't be blase about this but it
appears people
are being careless vietnam is forcing
80 000 people to leave the popular
resort city of danang because of new
cases
infections are rising rapidly around the
world
australia recorded its highest daily
count monday
despite the fact that nearly 5 million
people in the state of victoria
are on lockdown we have too many people
who have symptoms and they are going to
work
and what that means even with mask
wearing that is an unacceptable risk in
terms of transmitting this virus
spain is also dealing with the surge in
cases as
is japan ukraine even belgium
in brussels the prime minister says the
reproduction rate of the virus
the number of people one infected person
can spread it to has been
above one for several days leading to a
search in cases
as a result for the next month people
can only interact with five
others what is clear that
pressure on the virus successfully
pushes the numbers down release pressure
on the virus
and the numbers can creep back up since
january the world health organization
has been pleading with people to take
the virus seriously
noting that travel bans can't be kept up
indefinitely
and multiple measures are needed to stop
transmission
so whether we're dealing with second
peaks within the first wave
or second waves in some senses is is not
the right question to ask
the question to ask is how much pressure
do you have
on the virus i mean i'm a living example
of what this virus can do and
how it is serious the 42 year old is
hoping by early next
year he'll be well enough to fly again
crystal gomez global news london
president donald trump's national
security adviser has just tested
positive for kovit 19 making him the
highest ranking official in the trump
administration to contract the virus
robert o'brien is now in self-isolation
and said to be experiencing mild
symptoms
o'brien appeared publicly with trump in
florida back on july 10
but it's unclear if they've met face to
face since then
one of o'brien's daughters has also
tested positive
and new covid19 cases continue to surge
across the united states places that had
seen very few cases such as hawaii and
montana
are now showing dramatic increases while
florida and california
are now considered the new new yorks and
in the nation's capital a quarantine
rule goes into effect today
as lawmakers debate more economic relief
for struggling americans
jennifer johnson reports with florida
and california topping new york as the
states with the highest number of copen
19 cases
vice president mike pence traveled to
miami where testing sites are
overwhelmed
local leaders telling residents to be
patient by the end of the week we will
have doubled the testing capacity at our
county run sites
over 420 thousand floridians have tested
positive for the virus
but crowds are gathering on miami
beaches and many residents are still
refusing to wear masks
they can't tell me i have to wear a mask
i'm not going to wear a mask
to make somebody else feel comfortable
places like florida hawaii and texas are
now facing a double whammy
hurricane season during a pandemic that
is already overwhelming hospitals
but the top white house advisor on the
coronavirus says she's also concerned
about what's happening in several other
states
we do believe that there are states that
do need to close their bars
to decrease indoor gatherings to less
than 10
to really make it possible to control
the pandemic
before it gets worse in states like
kentucky
indiana ohio tennessee and virginia
as president trump visits a biotech firm
working on a vaccine in north carolina
america will develop a vaccine very soon
and we will defeat the virus the largest
clinical trial in the world begins this
week
30 000 americans have volunteered for it
this is one of 25 potential vaccines and
clinical trials across the globe
according to the world health
organization but there are no guarantees
any of them will work
there's not going to be a magic bullet
but hopefully a vaccine that gets
approved lessens severity of illness and
hopefully promote some degree of heard
immunity more broadly
washington dc has become the latest to
require a 14-day quarantine
for people coming from hot spots as
leaders desperately try to keep the
virus under control
and on capitol hill republicans have
finally unveiled their latest economic
stimulus plan
federal pandemic unemployment benefits
for millions of americans
expire friday jennifer johnson global
news
washington well it's expected to be a
big week
on parliament hill as prime minister
justin trudeau is grilled over the wee
charity controversy and his government's
now cancelled contract to administer a
900 million dollar summer student grant
program
the prime minister and his chief of
staff katie telford will testify before
the house of commons finance committee
on thursday and we's co-founders
brothers craig and mark kilberger
will also have their moment in the
spotlight facing questions on the affair
tomorrow
our michael couture is following all of
those developments for us and he joins
us now from ottawa
mike well jeff opposition mps are
gearing up for what could be
high political drama over the next few
days among the questions they want
answered
how did the price tag for the student
grant program
seemingly change today we're launching
the new
canada student service grant the
original program was supposed to be
worth 912 million dollars but documents
presented to members of the finance
committee
and shared with the media show the
government was only going to pay
543.5 million dollars
to have the we organization run a
student volunteer program
and opposition mps want to know where
the rest of the money
was going to go all the financials just
keep changing on us we can't seem to get
a straight answer which i think is also
very concerning
500 million was supposed to be earmarked
for grants to students who took part in
volunteer programs the remaining forty
three and a half million
would be to administer the program which
had hoped to help up to one hundred
thousand students
now we backed out of the agreement july
third citing controversy
over the liberals handing the
organization a soul-source deal
which includes ties between the charity
and both families of prime minister
trudeau
and finance minister bill morneau there
is evidence
for both the prime minister and minister
and the finance minister mourinho
that they were acting for a dishonest
corrupt intent trying to help one of
their families favorite charities
a part of the contract saw the
government already pay 30 million
dollars
up front to the charity on june 30th
however we sent out this copy of the
agreement with footnotes showing the
money
has not been drawn upon and funds will
be repaid by we in full
the details of repayment are presently
being worked out
with the government now also testifying
tomorrow is the former
chair of we charity's canadian board of
directors michelle douglas confirmed to
global news
that she resigned in march citing
concerning developments
at the organization jeff
michael couture in ottawa thanks mike
the growing calls to defund the police
coming up a new poll reveals how
canadians feel about proposals
for an overhaul welcome back
it's been exactly two months since regis
korchinsky paquette fell to her death in
toronto
following an interaction with police her
story along with the deaths of george
floyd and others
have sparked calls to defund the police
but a new ips's poll for global news
shows canadians are deeply divided on
the issue
and as our mike draulie discovered the
split is largely along
generational lines
the family of ajaz chaudhry was worried
when they called 9-1-1
the 62-year-old they say was
schizophrenic and needed medication
they expected an ambulance but police
showed up instead
and chowdhry was shot and killed clearly
the police just does not look like
they've been capable of having any type
of mental
health cases a billion dollars for
authorities
that are meant to protect and serve us
but they're doing the complete opposite
no justice no peace of belief
it's cases like chowderies that continue
to fuel the movement
calling for police forces to have their
budgets reallocated
which is better known by the catchphrase
defund the police
what is certain amongst canadians is
they're uncertain on this issue
in an ipsos poll conducted for global
news 51
support the idea of defunding police and
redirecting money into community
services
where you see the divide is along
generational lines
gen zed and millennials are far more
supportive than
gen x and boomers even with george
floyd's death in the u.s
and canadian cases like chowdhury's
freshen their minds
i can't believe that those people would
hear those things
and just refuse to respond or choose to
ignore it
i think that perhaps we just
aren't reaching them with the tools that
we're currently using and so maybe we
just need to
be in more places where
the news is delivered to them still she
says compared with where black lives
matter was with the issue a year ago
it's progress the protest did lead to
lively public debates
in june toronto rejected a 10 percent
cut to its policing budget
and vancouver said no to a one percent
cut
edmonton however agreed to reallocate 11
million dollars over two years
but no decision has been made on how it
will be spent
here's a real opportunity right now and
if all we do is look at the police
and we don't look at the underlying
societal issues that drive
why the police are responding to these
kinds of calls then then we're not going
to fix anything it's just going to be
more the same
and all a jazz chaudhry's family wants
right now
is something good to come from his death
microwave global news toronto
still ahead police reveal disturbing new
details about the gunman behind nova
scotia's
worst mass killing
this is the largest mass shooting in
canada
in our lifetimes
gathered in halifax today calling for a
public inquiry into nova scotia's
deadliest mass shooting back in april
the protest was sparked by the
government's announcement last week
that a three-person panel will review
how police responded
but families and friends of the 22
victims say that process lacks the power
and transparency
to conduct a proper investigation
and we're learning some disturbing new
allegations tonight about the man behind
that shooting
according to newly unsealed court
documents gabriel wartman had allegedly
been smuggling drugs and guns from the
state of maine
for years that's according to people
interviewed as part of the police
investigation
the documents also contain allegations
that wertman had its number of secret
hiding spots on his properties
wartman was shot dead by police in april
after killing those 22 people
and lawyers for huawei executive mong
wang zhou argued in federal court today
for the release of more
information relating to her arrest in a
virtual court appearance her legal team
pushed to see details from a set of
redacted government documents
her lawyers want to find out more about
the planning and execution of her arrest
at vancouver international airport
in december 2018 including who was
involved
they also want to see if there was
information about
cooperation and evidence sharing between
canadian and u.s agencies
her extradition proceedings are expected
to continue into 2021
still ahead pandemic problems could
cause a major league
strikeout even before the seasons in
full swing
looks like they're going to need a
bigger boat that finn sighting wouldn't
excite everyone but this family in nova
scotia drove their boat
to get a closer look it's believed to be
a great white shark which would make it
the first sighting in that area this
year
and some much needed good news for
hockey fans the nhl says there were no
positive cases of covid19 last week as
players dust off their skates for the
start of the stanley cup playoffs
teams are arriving in their bubbles in
toronto and edmonton
getting ready to hit the ice for the
first round of the qualifiers
starting saturday but major league
baseball is now canceling games after
opening the season
just last week tonight mike armstrong
looks at whether the baseball season
could crumble
before it gets into full swing
that ball's pulled down the left field
miami marlins players voted to play this
game sunday night
despite knowing three players had tested
positive for kovit 19.
what they didn't know was that monday
morning there would be
more between players and staff according
to espn
they're now up to 14. right between the
legs it's thrown a wrench
into everything the players are stuck in
philadelphia game one of their next
series is postponed
and the team they just played and shared
a field with for close to four hours
sunday
it's series philly's yankees is
postponed as well
rounding third heading for ole miss
gosselin it's fair to say that guys are
concerned
we're talking about these guys traveling
back to their homes and their families
and their kids
and it's the reason we want to be safe
now major league baseball brought in
rules to try to mitigate transmission
it's been
chewing tobacco and sunflower seeds and
supposedly high fives
not if you go by the celebration after
this home run nobody's happier than
gilito right there
someone in that pirates dugout has been
tossed there were
scenes like this one a manager and
umpire putting on masks for an argument
but there are now questions as to
whether that's enough
to work and stay socially distanced
we're all human beings
you know and we're playing through some
tough times we have struggles
these guys have families i have family
we think about that stuff
unlike the nhl and nba baseball didn't
try to come back in any sort of a bubble
off the field players were on their own
some predicted it wouldn't work
and question the sincerity of the effort
i don't think they were ever
really interested in pushing a season i
think if it just it worked
then great and if not oh well now even
playing and
living in a so-called bubble is only as
secure as the people in it
the nba has ordered a clippers player
quarantined for 10 days
blue williams locked in blue williams
was let out of the bubble for a funeral
last week
but also went to a strip joint mike
armstrong global news
montreal and that is global national for
this monday i'm jeff semple tonight's
your canada is rice lake
in north vancouver bc we love seeing
your canada
so please email your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching donna frieza we'll
be back here with you tomorrow
have a great night
[Applause]
[Music]
you